what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can help decide what direction
the content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable
future okay so Marvel the end is a story
I've been dancing around for quite some
time and I've been trying to find a way
to cover it just because of the fact
that it's extremely cool it's it's an
extremely cool set of events in the
sense that this basically Thanos
destroying the Marvel
Universe now something to keep in mind
here is that this story is not in
continuity Marvel the end all the
stories a tie to Marvel the end so like
Fantastic 4 the end Punisher wolver rain
um X-Men the end these are all alternate
reality Stories the only ones that I
know of that actually intersect are
Punisher the end and Wolverine the end
just because of the fact that the
Wolverine story is actually a precursor
to The Punisher story then it talks
about how Spider-Man basically killed
the uh killed the Marvel Universe it's
it's really cool well not really killed
the mar universe so basically turned
Earth into like a planet full of
cannibals it's it's really cool it's
actually a pretty interesting story but
this story was was written by by Jim
Starland and it's actually kind of
interesting because it ties into the
events of like Infinity Gauntlet and I
think that with Jim Stalin's Infinity
Run where he did like Infinity Gauntlet
Infinity War Infinity Crusade so on and
so forth those were all I think
originally designed to be self-contained
stories they were designed to be outside
of existing continuity but infinity
gaunlet and infinity War became so
popular that Marvel tied them into the
continuities and so because of that you
know events like Infinity finale and
infinity Revelations and stuff like that
and Marvel the end tie into the main
Marvel Universe you know only in so much
as like their history but the stories
themselves are outside of existing
continuity that's really kind of weird
it's an interesting situation it's kind
of a mishmash but in any event what this
story does is it initially picks up or
at least the the way a lot of these are
done is they're led into by Thanos
himself and and again you know Jim
Starin is I don't know he's a really big
fan of like drama you know the the
cosmic Opera he's a really big fan of
having the characters like put on shows
and so on and so forth and so what
Thanos really does just kind of give us
like this rundown of his past you know
says hey look you know I met mistress
death as a child and I you know
basically fell in love with her as I
Grew Older and all my Endeavors over the
course of my life have been based in the
root of gaining her affection so the
Cosmic Cube The Infinity Gauntlet all
these things have been done for the
purpose of trying to get her to love him
and so what this does is switch over to
a guy named ainan now ainat as he was
introduced to us was basically an
Egyptian pharaoh the problem with this
was that he essentially just vanished
and no one really knew what had happened
to him all they knew was that he was
just gone one day and it was really left
to the monarchy or I guess to the uh the
ruling line of his uh of his genealogy
to pick up where he left off but what we
learn is that he was effectively taken
away by extraterrestrials now we'll find
out more about that later especially
when he gets into his whole backstory Dr
Doom is watching the whole thing unfold
but at this point we switch over to the
X-Men now something to keep in mind is
that this period or this particular
story was written during Grant
Morrison's time on the X-Men Grant
morison and Chuck Austin and so because
of that we basically get a depiction of
the X-Men as they were designed during
the runs of Grant Morrison and Chuck
Austin but again this is not in line
with the main continuity the problem
with this is that because Charles Xavier
and because Jean Gray are such powerful
psychics they pick up what appears to be
this presence of a being named aonan
although they don't really know what it
means they're not they're not really
able to put the pieces together to
figure out what direction things are
going in but at this point we transition
outside of the known universe to the
realm of a girl named ATA now at Lea or
at leza whatever it is that you choose
to call her is effectively What's called
the custodian of the universe and she's
literally just designed to maintain its
safekeeping the codian of the universe
is one of those weird figures that
that's shown up maybe like five times in
the history of Marvel Comics he's shown
up so infrequently or I guess the role
has shown up so infrequently that you
could easily just assume it doesn't
exist and not really be affected by
anything but for this story Adas at Lisa
was a girl who was you know of course
from upstate New York but had such
incredible potential in terms of you
know controlling all facets of reality
that she was inducted into the role of
being the custodian of the universe and
she literally just safeguards it the
problem is that as a child she doesn't
fully grasp the true nature of her
responsibilities and so because of this
both gamor and Adam Warlock have
essentially been assigned to be her
caretakers now they had their own
stories that led up to them becoming
caretakers for at Ley I mean there's a
reason why they're here now we don't
really need to get into that but for the
sake of the story that's why they're
here now this will be important this
this whole thing will be significant the
reason why is because it'll give us a
reason for why it is that Adam Warlock
has this conversation with Thanos once
we get to the end of the story but at
this point we basically pick up with
Asgard now at this point in asgard's
history Asgard is being ruled by Thor in
you know with Odin effectively being
gone now the idea seems to be that Odin
has essentially passed on that he's
moved on to the next stage of his life
you know gone to the afterlife or he's
in the midst of the Odin sleep but the
idea here seems to be that regardless of
the circumstance Thor is essentially
running the show however in the midst of
Thor you know just doing whatever it is
that he does he's suddenly met by the
arrival of of aanat and what aanan says
is midgard or Earth has basically fallen
into disarray and aan is going to be the
one that restores order however Thor and
the gods of Asgard are instructed to
stay away now of course with this being
Thor the first question he has is who is
this guy and the second question is how
can I do the opposite of what he just
told me to do and that's essentially
what he does but from here we basically
switch over to Silver Surfer now of
course Silver Surfer is traversing the
spaceways and comes across the remnants
of a shiar vessel or a shiar fleet and
discovers Gladiator really holding off
for dear life now Gladiator is the head
of the Imperial Guard he's yet another
example of Marvel's equivalent to
Superman in terms of super strength
speed flight so on and so forth uh kind
of you know the cape the whole nine
yards even the way he looks in terms of
his uniform is relatively close to to
how Superman looks but gladiator's
powers are tied directly to his
confidence so if he lacks confidence his
powers will wne but if his confidence is
at his absolute Peak his powers will be
at their absolute Peak so it's really
kind of this caveat it's really easier
to defeat Gladiator using psychic or
using mental games as opposed to trying
to take him on with physical Force but
when Silver Surfer gets here he
basically discovers that this sh fleet's
been obliterated this is a huge deal
because the sh are one of the most
advanced you know technological
scientific races if not Waring races in
the Marvel Universe and so for some
group to you know or some being or
whatever it is to fly by and destroy the
entire fleet without without really
sustaining any damage whatsoever or even
stopping uh it really speaks volumes
about what kind of force they're up
against and so again Thanos uh jumps
back into this or at least Jim Stalin
gives us Thanos again and says that you
know he had been following this or been
analyzing this for quite some time
actually for about the past two years
whatever this energy source happened to
be that you know aen is drawing from it
sparked thanos's interest if for no
other reason than the fact that Thanos
wanted to attain it for his own and then
use it to carry out yet another grand
scheme not only that the you know
actions of aanat or his presence in the
universe has drawn the attention of Reed
Richards of the Fantastic 4 uh the X-Men
who have basically come together with
this threat and the reason for this is
because with Reed Richards and the
Fantastic 4 they are superheroes first
but they're explorers second and as
explorers they've seen so much much of
the universe but they also have a very a
very deep understanding of the nature of
the universe itself as well as all
different kind of instruments all
throughout the universe that show them
different things that are happening so
they can really see what's going on in
the universe at any one particular point
in time because they're so part and
partial to it just by way of explanation
they knew that there was something going
on out there but again the question was
what is this energ energy signature
that's heading to Earth what's going on
here and so with Charles Xavier and Jean
Gray essentially working together they
of course encounter the essence of aanat
and aanat says look Earth is an absolute
ponum right now I mean you got people
who are fighting each other you have
wars waging between you know societies
the Earth is basically in total shambles
and so he says what I'm going to do is
I'm going to restore order to it I'm
going to create peace where there wasn't
peace before my rule will be just and my
rule will be prosperous either you can
be part of it or you can be done away
with and so it's essentially akan and
say either you're part of the solution
or you're part of the problem stop being
part of the problem be part of the
solution but looking into the to the
hearts and Minds really of of Jean Gray
and Charles Xavier he comes to the
realization that they're going to work
against him it's just in their nature as
Heroes to essentially stand against him
and so because of this he basically
blasts the Xavier Institute and destroys
it in its entirety now from here we
essentially have Dr Doom watching these
events unfold now something that I hope
you notice here is that Jim Stalin's
paying special attention to people who
would likely covet the power of aanat
because remember Dr Doom is always
looking for absolute power you know the
the First Bank of absolute power for
Latveria is always open for business and
so because of this you know Dr Doom is
always is looking to gain you know
supreme power the same thing with Thanos
you know the the first make of Thanos is
open for business 24 hours a day when it
comes to acquiring power and so because
of this the two of them were always
looking for a way to to be the Supreme
Being of the universe more so than that
we also find out that within uh Egypt
itself a massive pyramid type device is
essentially landing and so again once
this happens they're all you know all
these different these world leaders laia
Dr Doom president of the United States
the whole n yards black panther they're
all teleported to the realm of aad not
into his place in Egypt now this is
everybody that leads any kind of tribe
whatsoever so like molem man's here
because he leads the mids so on and so
forth but when Aken arrives uh he
essentially says here's what's going to
happen I'm going to take over everything
I'm going to be the absolute ruler of
this world everyone here who is a world
leader will answer to me you know and in
turn I will tell you what you can and
cannot do and so he says just go forward
and await my commands await my
instructions from here things go exactly
as we would expect them to of course
with aanan being as powerful as he is Dr
Doom actually sends a spy device inside
of his own layer and begins looking at
everything now of course Dr Doom begins
to get a little overconfident here just
because of the fact that aanan hasn't
done anything to stop this device now
Jim serin also toys with this you know
the question is does aanat know it's
there or does he not know it's there if
he does know it's there is it part of a
plan to trap Dr Doom or is he simply
just not care about it being there it's
really one of these funny situations but
again you know with the X-Men seeming to
have been obliterated we basically have
Captain America calling in everybody
this part of the Avengers and I mean
every single one of them of course Aon
appears and says hey look I'm taking
over the world I mean either you can be
on my side or you can all perish in the
luming battle that you'll likely try to
try to create here of course the
Avengers basically say no that's not
going to happen you know we are not
going to be a part of this conflict and
so in response aanan eliminates them
gone like they're every last one of them
are basically destroyed or at least it
seems like they're destroyed now of
course Shield you know the the
governments of the world are launching
attacks against aon's base of operations
trying to find a way to penetrate this
force field and nothing's happening and
we you know some of the shield agents
say hey look we got to get the get the
Avengers here we got to get them you
know on our side fighting against this
guy Nick Fury chimes in and says hey man
I wish I could but they're gone like we
have no idea where they went to they're
they're they
history and so again from here it's
really just Dr Doom plotting now Dr Doom
looks at himself as you know the one of
the smartest beings of the Marvel
Universe and in a lot of ways he is he's
he's wildly intelligent but again it's
really his overconfidence here when he
says that he's going to be Humanity's
salvation now where the Silver Surfer is
again continuing his travels across the
cosmos with the intention of arriving on
Earth and trying to Aid the Earthbound
Heroes as best he can he's intercepted
by Thanos and teleported aboard thanos's
ship now when he gets there he basically
finds the Defenders now this is Jim
Starin hailing back to the original
Defenders roster I mean well not really
the the original original but for the
most part the defender roster as it
existed under Doctor Strange so name of
the Submariner Captain Marvel uh The
Incredible Hulk Silver Surfer it's
really just kind of grabbing you know
some of these older teams and bringing
them in and so in terms of the the
timeline in terms of the chronology and
Marvel's overall timeline I would say
that this story if it were in continuity
would probably take place around the
time of the first or second interation
of the Defenders but from here we jump
to Spider-Man and Daredevil and this is
really just jyst and telling us hey the
superheroes Aren't Dead you know they're
they're not all annihilated they haven't
all been destroyed instead they're all
essentially being held prisoner more so
than that they've been held prisoner and
they're put on display for the world to
see what happens to those who basically
defy aanat so it's really him just
showing the power that he possesses
here's all your X-Men all your Avengers
Earth's Mightiest Heroes they're all now
under my control you know they're all
now being held prisoner no one's coming
to save you and so from here we
basically pick up with Thor and Zeus now
this is Again part of the whole Sky
fathers thing the pantheon of Earthly
beings who stand as gods for Earthly
civilizations again Mo for the most part
every planet has their own you know
Earthly God quote unquote but when it
comes to Earth Vishnu Thor Zeus you know
all these different beings that
represent traditional Earthly religions
are represented as the sky fathers now
of course we have Zeus and Thor speaking
with a couple of the cosmic entities and
they essentially step up and say hey
look you know we have to do something
here there's something that has to be
done but the issue is that when Master
order and Lord Chaos go to Eternity and
Infinity The Cosmic entities that
represent all space and time in the
universe there's like there's nothing we
can do here you know they're just kind
of like hey look we're powerless against
whatever power aanan has for whatever
reason we cannot do anything to stop him
and so it's really just Jim Starin
saying hey here's how bad things are no
one can stop this guy I mean he has
absolute power now we'll find out just
how deep this absolute power goes but
what we end up doing is jumping over to
Dr Dooms he's basically you know
continuing to monitor the ship but he
also comes across what appears to be a
stasis capsule and finds himself
confined inside which means that
somewhere along the line in the future
Dr Doom is going to be taken prisoner
and so in his mind his time to act is
extremely limited it's extremely small
and the time is now he has to do
something in order to to topple aanan at
the same time we also have Thanos in
them continuing to to monitor everything
inside of here you know monitor all
these different events going inside of
aanan ship now at this point this is
where Starin begins to transition into
the story of aanan where he basically
says here's the power that he possesses
and here's how he got it what happens is
ain's basically took the spirit of a
being that's long since been dead that
essentially killed aon's son who took
over for his rule after he had vanished
and then you know took the place of
aanat son aanat has this guy Spirit you
know brought him back from the dead and
begins to torture him but in the process
explains his backstory in saying that as
the pharaoh of Egypt when he was taken
away by these you know Celestial beings
that these were beings that effectively
looked to the universe as a whole and
saw it as inherently chaotic the
universe in and of itself was you know
it it had no real Rhyme or Reason people
would do Insane things people would do
violent things and so what happened was
these Celestial or I guess the celestial
order as they call themselves began
going about the cosmos and grabbing you
know certain individuals and basically
saying we're going to bestow you with
this infinite power the heart of the
universe we're going to give you the
ability to tap into it and when you're
able to tap into it you're going to have
absolute power and you're basically
going to be Regents we're going to put
you in different parts of the universe
and you're going to rule that part of
the universe under our belief system now
what Aenon says is that one when he was
first bestowed with the ability to tap
into this this heart of the universe's
power it was wildly overwhelming I mean
the the level of of power that he was
dealing with it literally allowed him to
do whatever he wanted to with the
universe and so it was very very
difficult to grasp not only that he was
only bestowed with a fraction of its
power it wasn't until he was officially
inducted into the views of these of the
celestial order that he was effectively
allowed to become this full you know I
guess tap into the full might of the
heart of the universe now something else
to point out here something that I want
to make mention is this Celestial order
these are not the celestials that we're
used to all right these are not the the
guys that irishan the judge and so on
and so forth it's not like that these
are basically just a race of aliens now
we'll find out you know later on down
the line basically where it is that they
came from but ultimately the entire
situation is being watched by the
skyfathers they're essentially
monitoring everything aonan becomes
aware of this and attacks them now Thor
and Zeus are able to escape but all the
other skyfathers are completely
obliterated they're destroyed with the
greatest of ease and so what happens is
Dr Doom sits down and says okay fine
now's my time aen has basically run mad
with power it's my chance to effectively
take his place and to provide what's
considered to be Swift and adequate
judgment now the problem with this is
that in the present day aanan has
essentially taken all the villains of
you know on Earth and had them operate
as his own Imperial Army now a lot of
those guys did that willingly you know I
mean when you when you have like the
absorbing man you know he willingly
joined aanat for the purpose of you know
hey you know basically making the
argument it's better to De better to be
on the devil's right hand than in his
path but with regards to Dr Doom himself
he actually uses this time platform and
travels into the past now the time
platform that Dr Doom has is that's
something that he's had for quite some
time that the time platform is not
really new that's been in Marvel's
continuity for a while now and it's
actually been used in several different
stories most notably Age of Ultron when
uh Will Rain used it to go back in time
and kill Hank Pim the issue is that
again Dr Doom has a lot of hubber here
and so when he goes back to the past his
goal is to essentially stop aonan from
being taken by the celestials and take
his place the issue is that as you know
as soon as he gets there and he tries to
take aanat out we learn that aonan has
total control over space and time which
means he can time travel and so he'd
essentially gone back into the past and
captured Dr Doom hence the reason why Dr
Doom saw himself held captive in the
first place he had basically just
engineered his own defeat but because of
this Thanos says okay look the only way
for us to really defeat aanan is to
essentially cut off his access to the
heart of the universe we have to go to
where he's drawing this energy from we
have to harness it and then we have to
you know essentially take it away from
him now of course silver server has all
kinds of reserves he's like hey look
guys if we take Thanos with us to where
the heart of the universe is going to be
this is Thanos he's he's going to take
it like he's going to do bad things
because when you're Thanos that's what
you do you just do bad stuff now of
course Thanos makes the argument like no
no no no that's not the case that's not
the case you know my goal here is to
effectively save things the problem with
this is that they brought along the
Incredible Hulk and so when they get in
and the idea is to basically use stealth
and use gu to achieve their goal The
Incredible Hulk sees a robot and he's
just like there's a robot and he smashes
it and then it alerts the celestial
order to their presence so there goes
you know any real measure of
stealth and so what happens is Thanos is
actually pretty smart here Thanos uses
this as a distraction he basically says
okay fine if the celestial order is
going to be going against the combined
mind of doctor strange name of the
Submariner Captain Marvel and the
Incredible Hulk then IUS and the Silver
Surfer as well then I'm going to step in
and I'm basically going to steal the
heart of the universe and that's exactly
what he does you know while they're all
distracted the Silver Surfer turns
around just in time to realize what's
going on and tries to stop you know
Thanos but Thanos ultimately just takes
complete control of the heart of the
universe now from here what this what
this does is it basically elevates
Thanos now on the surface it would seem
like having the power of the heart of
the universe would be like having the
power of The Infinity Gauntlet right I
mean it would allow him to bend space
and time you know to manipulate all
facets of time and space that's what the
Infinity Gauntlet did but the difference
between the heart of the universe and
The Infinity Gauntlet is minor but is
huge at the same time because they both
do distinctly different things now of
course Thanos talks about you know going
through and finding it to be completely
disorienting experiencing this entire
thing the issue with this is that at the
same time with the heart of the universe
effectively having been taken the
containment field that was designed to
keep the heart of the universe uh from
escaping was still active despite the
fact that there was nothing for it to
protect and so the result of this is
that the stasis field effectively
collapses in on itself the ship's
destroyed destroyed and everybody on the
Defenders is killed Doctor Strange
Silver Surfer I don't know why that's
funny but Doctor Strange Silver Surfer
all those guys they're all obliterated
and it's really just Thanos and so from
here he basically goes on a quest to
eliminate all the competition and it's
actually really cool the first thing he
does is jump back into the past now of
course he gets there at around the same
time that Dr Doom gets there but where
Dr Doom fails Thanos seizes aonan and
takes him to the present now this is the
difference between the heart of the
universe and The Infinity Gauntlet what
aonan does with regards to the heart of
the universe is the same thing than did
with The Infinity Gauntlet and the
universe ainan tapped into the heart of
the universe aanan was able to use the
heart of the universe's power to achieve
whatever it is that he wanted to do much
like Thanos with The Infinity Gauntlet
when Thanos had the gauntlet he was able
to manipulate the universe he was able
to do whatever he wanted to it make it
malleable and and control it and
restructure it and so on but with the
heart of the universe Thanos is the
universe he basically is the source of
power that aanan is trying to manipulate
the difference here is that where aanan
was able to manipulate the heart of the
universe to achieve his own goals now
that Thanos is the heart of the universe
it's like you know it's it's essentially
become sentient it's like the heart of
the universe has its own thinking will
of its own and aanat can't make it do
whatever he wants to and so because of
this aanat is essentially powerless
Thanos overpowers him and basically
takes him out now this is where things
also begin to get kind of crazy but it's
also where we start running into the
scenario that the entire universe starts
mobilizing against Thanos one of the
things that we learn is that he
basically goes more than 2,000 years
into the past to when this Celestial
race basically first encountered the
source that was the heart of the
universe and what they did is they
essentially took it and they began to
use it for their own ends essentially
becoming the celestial order that we
knew and then ultimately you know
imbuing this power on aanan and whoever
else you know they chose to follow their
own line of thinking with Thanos
destroying them it actually creates a
bit of a paradox if their actions in
becoming the celestial order and
eventually bestowing aonan with the
powers of the heart of the universe
allowed Thanos to gain the heart of the
universe itself because it created these
current events if none of that happened
then why would Thanos still have the
power of the heart of the universe the
reason why this is a contradiction is
because it doesn't make any sense but it
also shows us just how powerful Thanos
is in the sense that he can basically
ignore contradictions and that's usually
how it works when it comes to The
Infinity Gauntlet The Cosmic Cube it
allows its wielder to do whatever they
want to in the universe even if it
defies the laws of physics or it creates
contradictions it doesn't matter they
can do whatever it is that they want to
the problem with this is that with
Thanos having so much power The Living
Tribunal exists to basically maintain
Cosmic order the Living Tribunal sits
down and it says okay look this universe
has eternity and infinity and it has you
know power and so on and so forth but
what he says is with Thanos having the
heart of the universe it means that he
now has absolute power as an individual
the heart of the universe isn't just an
energy source that he can tap into he is
the heart of the universe basically
Thanos is the universe in sentient form
and so what the Living Tribunal begins
to do in the background is effectively
begin going around grabbing all the
cosmic entities from galatis to Eternity
to Infinity you know to to all the
celestials master order Lord Chaos you
know mistress love sire hate every
single one of these Cosmic entities and
begins moving them against him
essentially begins moving all these
beings you know towards defeating Thanos
not only that Thanos also comes to a
realization while he's in in possession
of the heart of the universe and what he
learns is that there's essentially a
cancer in the universe now what this
cancer is we'll find out here in a
second but Thanos says that he was only
able to figure this out by having the
heart of the universe there's something
wrong with the physical structure of the
universe itself and that his job should
be to fix it that it seems as though
that circumstances have been engineer in
a way that led to this particular event
and ultimately gave him that power and
so what happens is he basically tells us
all this started with Wonderman Simon
Williams and the reason why it started
with him is because he was the deao
first hero to be resurrected from the
dead now the reason why he says this is
a major issue is because this is
effectively Jim Starin making the case
Heroes who are coming back from the dead
is a disruption of the natural order
Thanos goes as far as to say It's A
disruption of the natural order that
when beings die they should stay dead
they should not be able to come back
from the dead the fact that they can
return because of the fact that that
guys like Colossus Wolverine all these
all these different characters who have
essentially died and come back have
ultimately disrupted the structure and
the Order of things and so he says I'm
effectively going to fix that problem
I'm going to undo all of that now the
issue is of course that he's met by
eternity and this is when Jim Stalin
tells us how powerful Thanos is with the
heart of the universe we would normally
say that he is the universe embodied you
know he's just the physical structure
you know the universe and physical form
this is not the case instead Thanos has
the power of the one above all and we
know this when he's talking to Eternity
and what he says is surely eternity you
must sense that everything the almighty
was I now am did you ever demand
anything from him this is basically
Thanos saying I am the power of one
above all because if Thanos were the the
equivalent of Eternity he wouldn't say
that he would say I have the same power
as you instead he says I am the power of
the Almighty I am the power of the of
the one above all and so as a result
eternity tries to go against him and
Thanos seems or at least he's
successfully able to destroy eternity
the issue with this is that the Living
Tribunal makes his move the Living
Tribunal says you have been found
unworthy surrender your power now this
is what the Living Tribunal does that's
how things work the tribunal basically
all faces have to agree on a judgment if
all three faces agree on a judgment then
that judgment is carried out if any of
the three faces do not agree the
judgment is not carried out and so
because of the fact that all three faces
agree that Thanos is disrupting the
cosmic order by destroying eternity but
not taking its place as well as
possessing the power of the one above of
all and basically being what appears to
be you know having his own motivations
instead of you know sitting down and
being neutral in terms of good or evil
the result is that the Living Tribunal
says everybody's going to attack him and
so it's literally every single superhero
in the entirety of the Marvel Universe
going against Thanos now under normal
circumstances we would say hey man this
is really cool it's going to be like
Infinity Gauntlet right it's going to be
like this massive battle you know and
it's going to be really fun it's going
to be super drawn out nope Thanos lashes
out in anger and in response he just
destroys them all like he literally just
absorbs them all into a singularity back
into himself and then wipes out the
universe in its entirety and that's it
the universe has been totally destroyed
so when I when this story is you know
when I title this video Thanos destroys
the mar universe that's exactly what it
means it means he destroyed the universe
he didn't turn them into zombies you
know he didn't uh kill all the major
superheroes he totally obliterated the
universe now because of the fact that
Adam Warlock exists outside the universe
he appears to Thanos and he was like
what have you done
what in the hell have you done here man
now while this happens the conversation
between the two is of the utmost
importance and the reason why is because
Thanos basically says and even Adam
Warlock says this to a degree that all
this has been engineered Thanos didn't
just arbitrarily decide to to take the
heart of the universe Thanos didn't just
arbitrarily decide to use it to destroy
the universe that all of this was
foreseen and all of these steps were
taken now Thanos taking the heart of the
universe was his own choice but the one
above all knew this would happen and the
reason why the one above all knew this
would happen is because it's the one
above all it sees and knows everything
that's going to happen and so what we
learn here is that this imperfection in
the universe basically the fact that
Heroes were dying and coming back
consistently was leading to the
universe's own cancerous state it was
leading to its own destruction and so
because of this Ros end of himself in
the story essentially had cancer and was
going to die Thanos also came to the
realization that the only way to
basically fix this problem was to
eliminate the idea of Resurrection that
whenever anybody died they were never
going to come back that they were always
going to stay dead now in true this was
really just kind of self-contained to
Jim Starin in the sense that he was
basically making the case if anybody
dies in his stories they're not going to
come back this really wasn't him saying
hey guys this is how things are now in
all of Marvel Comics whenever somebody
dies they never come back that's that's
not the case people will usually always
come back especially because of the fact
that there were resurrections even after
this story was written but the general
consensus here is that the one above all
essentially sat down and said okay at
this point in time these you know weird
aliens are going to capture the heart of
the universe when they do that they're
going to take step STS for the next
2,000 years that will eventually lead to
the formation or I guess to to aanan
being taken and being given this power
to the heart of the universe that will
eventually lead into Thanos becoming
involved and Thanos sees in the heart of
the universe and then he'll realize the
imperfection he'll fix the imperfection
and everything that the one above all
wanted to happen will eventually come to
fruition and so because of this Thanos
more or less talks to Adam Warlock as
they continue their conversation and
Adam Warlock says okay look I mean
surely you can't believe that this is
the way things need to be I mean this is
literally just an empty Universe you
know like there's there's nothing left
to live for here and so Thanos says okay
fine this cancer of the universe is this
Resurrection will be eliminated I will
bring the universe back but from this
point going forward no one will ever
come back to life no one will ever be
resurrected and so as the story ends we
effectively have all these superheroes
going back to their normal States before
all these events took place not only
that Adam Warlock and the way this seems
to end Adam Warlock is just kind of left
with the idea Thanos allowed himself to
die he finally joined mistress death in
the realm of the Dead achieving what it
was that he'd been searching for you
know all these years of his life but
with that being said guys uh that's
pretty much it Marvel the end that's
Thanos destroying the entire Marvel
Universe but if you guys are new here to
Comics explain make sure you hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and uh yeah I will catch you
all later
[Music]
peace